[Musique]
de ses rêves est là
stylé africa 24 alors rien ne présage et
son déplacement sur le sénégal où
devaient avoir lu le test final qu'elle
est déterminée toute sa vie elle assure
faire le déplacement ainsi changer le
cours de l'histoire
éduqué par un père qui croit dur comme
fer en l'espace d'une éducation à la
limite perfectionniste et empreinte de
techniques d'intimidation de
maltraitance digne de vrais scénarios
syllabe de travail ou des mêmes les
techniques d'interrogatoire de fbi à
issia et il a su se découvrir une
identité
la forge est en train de percer
messieurs si jusque là vous êtes en
train de vous demander quel est le lien
entre ces deux histoires qui apparemment
n'ont rien en commun
hélas le monteur de réussite entre elle
et bien n'ayez crainte des justes une
très belle preuve que vous êtes en train
de bien me suivre et que vous êtes au
coeur du top de rave qui vous parle
aujourd'hui du grand handicap le regard
de l'autre alors pour nos constats
personnel j'ai juste besoin de n'amène
si tel est votre cas
alors je ne sais pas si vous êtes arrivé
une fois d'être dans un service public
et d'être accueilli comme si vous étiez
la source de tous les mouvements du
prestataire de services à la mène audrey
là je crois que je n'ai plus un constat
personnel mes objectifs et donc on va
faire des recherches à notre niveau on
verra alors de ceux ci des cocktails que
question qu'on peut bien se poser un jeu
laisse libre cours à votre imagination
elle permettait quand même coup
j'oriente avec une ou deux questions
d'accord la première serait par exemple
est ce que le client n'est plus roi
comme on le dit et la deuxième est ce
que ces prestataires de services ont
payé pour justifier tel ou tel
manquement à l'éthique professionnelle
je ne pense pas parce que je vous dise
quels que soient les problèmes qu'on a
il n'y a rien qui justifie qu'on manque
du respect aux clients et généralement
il ya deux options qui se présentent aux
clients il se dit la première c
je suis un je réagis pas je maîtrise
seigneur un peu comme à la martin luther
qui vous voyez donc que cherche on
trouve plus tard puisqu'il fille merde
quoi ça c'est un peu la loi du talion
oeil pour oeil dent pour dent
généralement dans les deux cas y'a rien
de bon pourquoi parce que notre corps
est comme passe communicants tout ce qui
entre eux soit forcément d'une façon ou
d'une autre
mais là c'est bien mais c'est jamais au
prorata du degré de réception et pour ça
certains vous leur faites juste une
petite chose ils sont flammes font dix
mais merde quoi
pour comprendre la chose il faut juste
aller un peu en arrière et vous allez
voir que c'est l'accumulation de petites
choses non dits et ont conduit à ça et
égoïste de notre part de se dire au nom
de la liberté d'expression j'ai le droit
de manifester ma colère comme je veux
mais ça nous revient toujours à la
figure oui parce que comme dans le
premier quart martin luther king ou dans
le deuxième
malcom x on paie les pots cassés et ça
devient comme un boomerang un feu de
brousse et embrase notre environnement
immédiat et longtemps ça nous revient et
il ya autre chose qui revient là comme
conséquence c'est sur le plan
professionnel parce qu'il est prouvé par
un collègue à moi vous allez voir à
travers tout monstre vite que je n'ai
que des collègues célèbre un collègue
célèbre à moi ici c'est un professeur et
il s'appelle cholin qu il a trouvé dans
ce qu'il appelle rapide cette vente est
ce que 15% du succès du travail n'est
pas dû à notre technicité notre
connaissance sur le tas ou dans les
universités les plus prestigieuses mais
à notre degré de bonheur je sais que ça
vous en bouche un coin hein oui
et devinez ce qu'il y a que c'est notre
intelligence qui a boosté notre
créativité notre productivité
mais quelque chose rendez-vous l'argent
barney seehofer oui parce que les
clients quand on ne compte pas elle peut
lui faire payer à coup de millions mais
aux prestations de faire service mais
tenez vous bien ce n'est pas traitée
rapport aux prix qui est là mes qualités
humain c'est-à-dire a été priée valeurs
humaines qui est là donc une pêche
d'enfer attention il n'y a rien qui qui
qui vaille la peine qu'on fasse
attention à l'humain voilà donc quelque
chose qui découlent de ça et que j'aime
bien c'est cette phrase là qui devient
une chanson que les gens chantent et
fais ce que tu m aimes ce que tu fais au
point que je me demande si on fait
attention à cette valeur intrinsèque de
chaque mois à l'intérieur
heureusement que c'est la devise de
certaines personnes comme un autre
collègue célèbre un mois hellip
etchebest oui la célèbre cuisinier et
les stars comme moi mais lui de télé
réalité ma devise à moi c'est d'être
sincère et déterminés dans ce que je
fais et d'avoir surtout l'amour du
travail bien fait et ça lui réussit et
s'il ya quelqu'un qui fait la même chose
c'est la première personne dont j'ai
parlé dans mon introduction savait quoi
et qui est arrivé très en retard le jour
là mais elle a quand même eu le culot de
faire dire au directeur d'africa 24
telle est la poule aux oeufs d'or
d'atrium d'africa 24
et la conséquence est gay aujourd'hui
elle est la correspondante d'africa 24
au togo vous l a fait au delà des mais
ce qu'elle fait de faire ce qu'elle aime
et qu'il allume adopté le regard des
autres pour arriver jusqu'au bout de ses
rêves et si je tiens à préciser que
quand je parle de dompter le regard des
autres n'est pas forcément les autres en
dehors de nous et aussi nous mêmes parce
que encore un autre collègue qui vient
lucide le père de la psychanalyse en
collègue oui voilà et il dit que nous
avons nous que lui l'appel sur moi mais
que j'appelle la city en miniature à
nous une juge qui est là qui dit [ __ ]
tu me pète discours alors ça te dit tu
peux pas ci fais pas ça c'est pas ci
fais pas ça heureusement qu'il ya le le
ca au la libido 1
nos rêves les plus fous sont là et puis
le mois qui est apparemment moon un peu
équilibrée qui il a à faire c'est lutte
là pour équilibrer les choses
et s'il ya quelqu'un qui fait cette
lutte déquilibre des choses c'est le
petit garçon dont j'ai parlé dans la
deuxième partie de mon introduction
handicapés ont le cachet à la maison
quand il y avait certains vous invité
vip
mais le paradoxe est que certains
essayent vienne qui avaient des enfants
en situation de handicap
mais la tendance pour le perte de dieu
où vous savez les enfants en situation
de handicap sont comme les autres
enfants il faut en prendre soin mais lui
cache pour lui c'est du genre tu pas
bout je tue pas bougé un dernier un beau
jeu et oui il est là dit bouge pas mais
si on pensait que cet état de chose
c'est juste un cas isolé mais vous
leurrez puisque c'est c'est un peu le
lot des enfants en situation de handicap
du mince ya la confirmation qui est
donnée par le directeur affaires
sociales de la préfecture de mots
lorsqu'on conduisait quelques enquêtes
là pour faire le tournage d'un
documentaire sur l'éducation inclusive
au togo la situation des enfants en
situation de handicap n'était pas mieux
il en existe et on les cache et aussi
heureusement qu'il a dit on est caché ça
veut dire qu'il ya eu amélioration et je
peux confirmer par quatre feuilles
le premier c'est que tout au long de ce
documentaire oui on va les enfants en
situation de handicap qui vont à l'école
deuxième vous avez certainement des
enfants en situation de handicap qui
vont à l'école ou alors des amis c'est
pas le cas
mettez l'alcool a light bright troisième
sujet était le m 6 2 du lancement
officiel de ce programme national au
togo et à l éducation pour tous un
programme de la feta fédération
togolaise des associations de personnes
handicapées avec comme partenaire le
montaut ball est là gisèle et sybille m
et je vous confirme que les enfants en
situation de handicap vont à l'école et
pour finir moi même je suis en situation
de handicap
j'ai été à l'école et pour ça je me
permets ce français châtié devant vous
quoi mais pour revenir à cet enfant je
vous dis que sa situation n'était pas
heureuse mais il croit dur comme fer que
son père est né bon comme le dit l'adage
l'homme est bon c'est là qu'ils le coran
elle corrompt tellement bien qu'elle
créé de véritable psychopathe des aigris
des mal aimés qui traînent des blessures
émotionnelles imagerie cous de
véritables victimes et leur messe nous
dit que chaque cas en seconde
une personne met fin à ses jours non
seulement ce regard est handicapant mais
meurtrier
bravo à vous humanité il ya vous avez
réussi comme ça
et en parlant de victimes le petit
garçon dont je vous parlais ces mois
nourrit le petit garçon qu'on a caché le
vit maintenant que pour inspirer
d'autres personnes et j'ai appris à
surmonter tout cela par une forte dose
d'amour à remplacer ressentiment et n
par cette forte dose d'amour là je suis
en harmonie avec moi-même et avec mon
environnement
enfin j'estime que ça me réussit voici
un peu je suis alors je veux bien croire
que je suis un entrepreneur à succès
parce que je gère mon sens ce qui
s'appelle la polio serrures à vous allez
voir une box pour ça après je suis un
orateur fin en tout cas vous allez me
dire à la fin aussi j'ai gagné à ces
deux prix nationaux internationaux en
tant que speaker zh
j'ai fait quelques scènes du monde
notamment l'afrique coni voir bénin et
çà et là des faits aussi niwat
washington dc deux fois j'ai fait mes
ryland j'ai fait aussi opération sts est
universelle et caroline du nord et en
parlant de ça je suis un leader
certifié iso voilà par le gouvernement
américain à travers le programme mandela
washington township
je suis un animateur radio télé et
événementiel et où donc pour contacter
la voilà ok donc je fais tout cela je
crois que ça me réussit et maintenant si
vous voulez voir ou savoir le moteur de
réussite entre tout cela est très simple
est de se dire que vous être concentré
tout ce qu'on veut vraiment le se dit
qu'on va y arriver que l'humain
lendemain décevoir de nous faire du mal
là plutôt nous rende plus fort et plus
humain
et je vous propose une définition de
l'amour qui m'a aidé à faire ça mais je
veux aller plus loin que de proposer une
définition il voudrait que vous vous
leviez s'il vous plaît
rhône hier le bout alors vous allez dire
à votre voisin à côté de vous tenez lui
la main voilà vite à votre voisin
ceci est fait le sincèrement je t'aime
mais je veux juste que vous preniez le
temps de le savourer tout cela vous
allez voir qu'en faisant ça sincèrement
on va éviter bien de guerre il utile
dans le monde qu'on va éviter des
blessures émotionnelles inutile dans le
monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]